bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale un grand champion l'histoire du
jeu d'échecs avec jérôme on fera salle
jérôme cbi stephen alors aujourd'hui on
va voir un joueur qui a défrayé la
chronique des années 70 70 mais il a
joué bien après bien sûr qu'elle en
carrière son joueur danois
c'est bent larsen oui ben carsen un
joueur venu du froid mais qui avait
l'habitude de jouer de façon souvent
offensive en tout cas souvent peu
orthodoxe il aime bien des débuts
exotiques
il faut dire que son livre de chevet
quand il a commencé à des bulles à jouer
aux échecs c'était mind système de aaron
in the beach qui était un autre danois
un autre danois d'adoption et qui était
surtout l'un des pères de ce qu'on
appelait l'école hypermoderne on line in
the vie c'est donc on en a parlé dans
une autre émission c'est vraiment le
fondateur des nouvelles idées aux échecs
qui dépasse le les échecs foldingue j'ai
envie d'y romantiques du 19e qui étaient
là t'as qu'à te voir nadine qui va
mettre en place les grands concepts etc
et larsen est un peu sont finalement son
son métier puisqu'il danois aussi donc
il
cette filiation nîmes zollitsch larsen
qu'on ne peut que l'on peut oublier
voilà qui fait du danemark et des pays
des échecs aussi les pays scandinaves
qui se distingue quand même dans les
échecs
même les petits pays l'islande on l'a
dit lui toujours de très fort joueur la
norvège maintenant avec magnus carlsen
et le danemark avec in the beach et
larsen ce sont des sons des pays où on
joue alors larsen d'où il vient comment
il va écouter pas moins bien depuis
septembre 2011 ce qui malheureusement il
nous a quittés oui mais il n'allait pas
très bien dans son enfance non plus
c'est en été il était assez malade
donc il a commencé à jouer aux échecs
puisqu'ils étaient obligés de rester à
la maison il était un peu et quelquefois
alité et il commence à jouer à lire my
system et se met sérieusement aux échecs
autour de la vingtaine de sa vingtaine
d'années tout en continuant d'ailleurs
ces études là quand ces études
scientifiques donc étudiants joueurs qui
ont beaucoup hein
souvent ils sont encore étudiants joie
puis après ils choisissent aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs de plus en plus on a dans les
pays occidentaux des des professionnels
des ingénieurs des scientifiques qui ont
une carrière à chiquer d'à côté qui font
les deux et qui en général font les deux
bien conduire ils sont il faut pas le
juger deux moitiés mais on a plus en
plus de maîtres internationaux qui ont
une activité alors ils peuvent pas aller
au niveau du grand maître ou très peu y
en a quelques-uns d'entre eux comme j'en
ai corps par exemple
oui bon donc là il est étudiant en
jouant aux échecs pichelin il va s'y
mettre à fond mais là il fait des études
d'ingénierie civile il passe ainsi à ses
examens mais décide de se mettre
sérieusement aux échecs autour de 20 21
ans
d'accord si oui voilà il a un style on
l'a dit qui est plutôt dédaigneux des
nuls ils n'aiment pas faire faire des
nuls ils aiment bien adopter des styles
et un style un petit peu hétérodoxes d
des nouvelles populariser les idées de
l'imso vichy continue l'école hyper
moderne et ça fait de lui un très fort
joueur de tournoi parce qu'il ya un
style sans concession qui lui permet de
gagner de gagner beaucoup de points en
tournoi dans la période 67 70 qu'on peut
décrire comme son apogée
larsen remporté huit des neuf tournois
deux grand maître auquel il participe
oui ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup en
trois ans huit tournois deux grand
maître qu'avec des rues sympa avec oui
mais pas des tournois de nationaux au
danemark s'agit de très grands tournois
du reste les soviétiques le craignent au
moins autant que fischer il pense que il
a plus de potentiel pour aller gagner le
titre de champion du monde notamment
depuis qu'il a remporté l'international
dessous 167 avec un point et demi
d'avancé sur tous ses adversaires et les
soviétiques le craignent largement
autant que fischer cette période là
d'ailleurs
fisher et larsen sont les deux
représentants occidentaux les plus forts
à l'époque et ce sont deux personnes qui
ne s'apprécient pas beaucoup
ils sont ils se battent pour le
leadership et en 77 organiser un match
l'urss contre reste du monde et la
question se pose pour l'équipe du reste
du monde de savoir qui de fisher ou de
leur scène va être premier et chic
surtout avec alors ce qui se passe aussi
c'est que fisher depuis 66 je crois est
un peu sortie du monde des échecs parce
que il a appliqué une gueulante jamais
nérin parce que je n'étais pas d'accord
avec ce système les qualifications par
tournoi qui avantageait les équipes
enfin les joueurs russes qui jouait un
peu entre de façon à se ménager leurs
forces pour jouer contre les autres
joueurs
il voulait des matchs constat n'y avait
pas de match donc il était un peu sorti
en disant je joue plus le cycle de
championnat du monde
et comme il avait un peu mis sa part à
sa carrière entre parenthèses lors de ce
fameux match et finalement la question
de savoir qui va jouer au premier
échiquier se pose puisque fisher et en
parenthèses alors que larsen est
toujours très actif à elle avec deux
d'excellents résultats
oui il l'a dit il a gagné huit des neuf
tournois qu'il a disputés entre 67 et 70
il est légitime pour être aux premiers
échiquiers d'ailleurs il pose ses
conditions et il pose un ultimatum soit
ce sera le premier échiquier soit je ne
jouerai pas finalement les organisateurs
décident de faire jouer au premier
échiquier et il tient parfaitement son
rang donc à ce moment-là il apparaît
comme véritablement un danger pour les
soviétiques et puis une alternative pour
l'occident à un bobby fischer et et
chose étonnante fischer accepte parce
que oui j'espère aussi avait tendance à
poser ses conditions en général mais là
comme ils acceptaient le fait que comme
il n'était pas trop active non
finalement mais fisher a peut-être été
aussi surpris de se trouver face à
quelqu'un de caractère
on se souvient de l'anecdote de fisher
aux championnats du monde à reykjavik en
1972 ou lothar schmitt larbitre ne cesse
de reculer devant ses exigences et un
moment latarche ont-ils dit mais
pourquoi vous ne me prenez pas au
sérieux puisque j'essaie de tout ce que
vous dites pourquoi vous ne respectez
pas effrayer mais comment voulez vous
que je vous respecte puisque vous céder
tout le temps donc peut-être qu'il a été
surpris par l'attitude de l'art scène
par sa fermeté par par sa persévérance
et finalement elle a accepté de joe
deuxième est chic et ceci étant les deux
joueurs ont pu régler leurs comptes sur
l'échiquier un petit peu plus tard
puisqu'ils se sont croisés lors du cycle
de championnat du monde devait mener à
la finale de 1972 ils se sont affrontés
aux états unis à denver dans des
conditions climatiques qui était
mauvaise pour larsen faut quand même le
préciser parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours souffert des problèmes de son
enfance et c'est quelqu'un qui avait
besoin d'un air assez relativement frais
et le climat de denver qui n'est pas
très loin du désert du nevada était très
très mauvais pour lui et fischer là
alors on a pensé que ça serait vraiment
le clash le grand choc des deux
occidentaux et qu'il en ressortira un
match très très serré très tendue et en
réalité il ya pas eu de match
mon genre l'emporter 6 à 0 1 et 6 0
c'est énorme et c'est pas le seul à
avoir perdu 6 0
cette année la fin c'est à ce moment là
taille 9 et perdu 6-0 aussi votre
fischer mêmes petrossian a perdu je
crois 6 2 on y reviendra dans une
émission sur fisher bien sûr mais larsen
évidence et c'est un peu son alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé aux anglais en
60 ce soir neuf parce qu'on sente c'est
tigane international 2 dessous 2009 il
n'accède pas à la finale mondiale ex
c'était la finale c'est parce qu'ils
passent devant ces espèces qui passe
devant qui devient champion du monde
là il est battu par fisher dans ce
tournoi des candidats 6 0 c'est un score
très très peu fréquent à ce niveau de la
compétition
on peut dire d'une certaine façon que la
une partie la partie la plus brillante
de la carrière de larsen s'arrête à ce
moment là c'est un coup d'arrêt
terriblement et psychologiquement il est
marqué par sept par cette défaite
on le serait à moins il était attendu
comme un potentiel champion du monde et
il termine par 6 0 mach est quand même
très très dur en qui sait il perd le
leadership de façon à contester auprès
des occidentaux et puis petit à petit
ses résultats ses résultats pâtissent un
petit peu de
de ça sa condition physique aussi n'est
pas gelé dit extraordinaire il finit
d'ailleurs par aller de plus en plus
hors en argentine et puis même si
installée puisque la capitale argentine
est une station balnéaire bien connu
buenos aires est ce dire le bonheur
il date et il y rencontre une jeune
femme qui est qui les pousse du reste et
donc ils passent de plus en plus de
temps en argentine et puis va continuer
bien sûr à faire des allers-retours avec
l'europe où il a une maison à las palmas
et puis il continue à disputer des
tournois mais pas avec la même ferveur
et pas avec le même le même allant
psychologique
ouais donc il ya un avant et un après il
ya la bonne dose quoi en fait en avant
il ya les vins après des années pour
beaucoup de joueurs le fisher a été un
sommet wii qui a acquis à qui a séparé
le l'histoire du jeu d'échecs en deux
parties y aller avant fisher et un après
oui d'ailleurs taillé madoff qui a aussi
perdu 6-0 contre eux figurent la même
année et qui était un musicien
concertiste réputé et renommé à dix
après le 6-0 qu'il a encaissés contre
fischer au moins il me reste ma musique
oui d'une certaine façon dont les échecs
c'est un peu mort rien qui est
infranchissable donc voilà larsen a été
victime un petit peu du du syndrome
fischer il était victime d'un autre
syndrome qui est de plus en plus
répandue c'est qu'il a été le premier
grand maître international qui a été
battu par un ordinateur
oui ça c'est vrai outil en 1988 il a
peut-être pris le match un petit peu à
la légère mais pour la première fois à
un ordinateur bat est un grand maître
international de premier plan qui était
basse qui inaugurait une série puisqu'il
y aura d'autres grands maîtres qui
devront baisser pavillon
jusqu'à la garrigue et sport est cramé
gossip est chronique ça a été
annulé contre l'employeur maintenant les
ordinateurs sont en fait c'est comme
avoir une voiture une mobylette mais on
ne peut pas courir le 100 m avec la
voiture la mobylette ça serait pas
correct
non il faut pas jouer aux échecs avec
l'ordinateur aujourd'hui c'est interdit
et bien sûr les organisateurs sont très
attentifs bien sûr est ce que tous les
moyens de communication soit bloqué afin
qu'il n'y ait pas de problème avec toi
là donc on va voir une photo pour
reconnaître bent larsen ici voilà si on
peut montrer cette photo alors il efface
on reconnaît le joueur en face même si
on voit qu'une partie de son nom c'est
le grand victor cornouaille est là donc
on voit bien que larsen avec le drapeau
du danemark en train de noter sa feuille
de partie donc là on doit dans les
années 80 sans doute joué dans les
années 80 c'est un parent scène un petit
peu peu vieillissant et qui n'est déjà
plus au top mais il continue à disputer
des tournois grand maître bien entendu
dans lesquelles il a déjà des résultats
même en 76 il remporte les interzones
haut à bienne mais malheureusement une
paire en 77 dès les quarts de finale
donc il a continué à jouer au haut
niveau mais encore une fois il était sur
une pente descendante après denver
bien sûr alors ici on a un autre
document donc c'est pas une photo est un
document historique
puisque c'est une feuille de partie
entre j'ai l'air dont on a parlé dans
une autre émission sur les grands
champions legranger l'air aussi face
donc ici à leur scène
voilà c'est un document historique à
plus d'un titre déjà parce que j'ai
partie de l'histoire du jeu mais aussi
parce que vous ne verrez plus documents
en tournoi oui c'est un document pour
vieux dinosaures oui c'est vrai
puisqu'il s'agit d'une feuille
d'ajournement ouais il faut expliquer sa
vision est ce que c'est un ajournement
nation un ajournement et quand quand tu
es parti était trop était trop longue
on faisait une pause à un moment que les
joueurs puissent se reposer alors
o'grady le plus précisément c'est le
moment c'était le 40e au 40e c'est à
dire qu'ils auront donc les joueurs
avaient je crois deux heures et demie
chacun pour athènes le 40e coup ce qui
est très long parce qu'aujourd'hui on
est plutôt à deux heures par jour pour
toute la partie
40e coup pourquoi parce que c'est
souvent beaucoup de partis se terminer
avant le 40e coup donc on considérait qu
au delà on entrait dans les finales et
que pour que le jeu soit de bonne
qualité il fallait que les joueurs aient
le temps de réfléchir à cette fameuse
finale donc on a arrêté la partie au 40e
coup et celui qui a acquis c'était de
jouer de ses hauts blancs d'ailleurs
c'est les blancs qui devait jouer le 40e
41e coup mais ne le disait pas
l'adversaire les joueuses sous enveloppe
de jouer sous enveloppe c'est à dire
qu'il donnait ce coup effectivement
uniquement à l' arbitre et c'était cette
feuille qui faisait office de la
position qu'ils allaient reprendre le
lendemain
les noirs donc les blancs savez la
position mais ce n'était pas à eux de
jouer et des noirs savait parce que les
blancs avaient joué mais il avait toute
la nuit pour y réfléchir
c'est dans la nuit alors là larbitre
remplit tout simplement la date muraux
de la partie le nom des joueurs il
indique le matériel par exemple orange &
3 etc etc de façon à ce qu'on puisse
reconstituer la position de lendemains
qui ait pas d'erreur ouais et lundi que
la en allemand galerne 148 la 1e coup
j'ai galère amis je pense vous
enveloppent 141e cool indique qu'il a
déjà mis son enveloppe et qui lui a qui
lui a donné je pense voilà donc tu es à
la position d'un côté une enveloppe de
l'autre pour le coup et donc c'est une
fameuse finale d'ajournement
effectivement qu'il n'y en a plus du
tout lieu maintenant on fait des parties
du début à la fin dans la continuité on
fait plus alors pourquoi pour rôle pour
pour la raison d'un bon vin que c'est
plus court et concis
aujourd'hui on tourne à moderne va faire
trop de temps à jouer deux jours sur une
partie et ensuite aussi parce que les
ordinateurs sont là n'est qu'aujourd'hui
bon ben si on met la position dans une
machine on peut dormir tranquille mais
c'est à peu près quel sera le meilleur
coup à jouer sans avoir besoin d'y
réfléchir soi même ce qui est un
avantage considérable est sûre donc
c'est hors de question d'ailleurs on
soupçonne quelques parties de transition
entre l'ancienne époque et la nouvelle
entre kasparov et karpov notamment je
crois à même de la cbi je crois qu'il ya
eu il ya eu déjà il y avait des
ajournements encore assez d'être un des
derniers championnats du monde avec un
jour ne m'en si long et si ma mémoire
est bonne et il ya eu des soupçons que
ben l'ordinateur est tournée pour les
joueurs bon c'est à cette époque
l'ordinateur était pas très très fort
enfin en le faisant tourner tout là
toute la nuit ça pouvait éviter de faire
déjà des dégâts fait ça pouvait
peut-être même trouvé des bons coups
déjà à l'époque un et surtout dans les
championnats du monde c'était le bénin
égalité ou en tout cas il y avait des
différences entre les joueurs qui
avaient de très bons seconds en voir une
armée de grands maîtres soviétique
derrière eux oui et puis les joueurs un
petit peu plus solitaire je pense que ça
a joué des tours à kornoi en 78 e bay
city ou le match était très tendue
contre karpov karpov été très très très
soutenue par toute l'armada des grands
maîtres soviétique tandis cornouaille
était un homme un petit peu un petit peu
seulement il était soutenu par rei quine
de maître international anglais mais il
n'avait pas une armée avec lui de gens
pour réfléchir toute la nuit sur les
différentes positions
donc ça a sûrement joué dans le résultat
même de certains championnats du monde
très bien donc on va passer maintenant
en revenant sur le plateau puis on va
je vais mettre en place la partie de du
jour qui va illustrer la carrière de ben
carsen on a choisi ici alors c'est une
partie particulière puisque donc elle a
lieu à bruxelles en 87 en mode blitz
donc c'est une partie bits donc c'est
tout à fait intéressant parce que le bis
demande beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
d'attention et bon c'est pas face à
n'importe qui c'est quand même lite mais
face à kharkov legrand karpov en 87 il
est quand même toujours au top niveau
mondial puisqu'il vient où il va parce
que jouer qui est bien et où il vient de
jouer un championnat du monde face à
kasparov qui ne perd pas en plus si
ferry fait édifier match nul il fait 12
partout et même il mène à une partie de
la fin nous lie le banc qu'il est au top
niveau mondial à ce moment qu arnaud
donc battre car promène en blitz à ce
moment-là ça ça relevait du défi lire
donc
et donc si une partie vit c'est toujours
intéressant mon bide sur vous rappelle
le principe alors on a vu le jour de
manse et c'est intéressant puisqu'on a
ici l'opposé c'est l'ajournement c'est
sur deux jours parce que l'on dépasse au
40e qu'on prend beaucoup de temps pour
réfléchir et c'est bon mais là on est en
blitz et cinq minutes par joueur pour
tous et toute la partie
donc ça demande énormément d'attention
il faut quand même pas jouer n'importe
quoi surtout face à des grands maîtres
joue parfois des très très belle partie
en lice malgré que ce soit en partie
rapide c'est l'intuition qui prime sur
le calcul
donc on a souvent des jus du un jeu
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus aéré
beaucoup plus fantasque que des parties
lentes
oui les petites imprécisions qui donne
mais qui me donne un petit peu de sel à
la partie les positions sont rarement
plate et on a souvent des attaques
brillante effectivement 45 minutes pour
toute une partie par joueur s'est passé
pas si court que ça ça laisse un petit
peu de temps pour réfléchir à ça fait
dix minutes en tout et
peut-être même que c'est un blitz avec
rage ou trois secondes par joueur c'est
possible aussi donc pas sur ses
positionnements subite
on va voir s'amorcer vite ça veut dire
que si vous dépassez vos cinq minutes
mais vous avez perdu 6 et 5 minutes + 3
secondes à chaque coup mon rajoute trois
secondes à votre capital temps donc même
s'il vous reste très peu de secondes
vous avez toujours au moins trois
secondes à jouer et puis si vous jouez
découvrant une seconde que ça vous
rajoute deux secondes deux secondes deux
secondes ça vous donner ça vous vous
reconstitué au petit notre votre capital
donc on y va avec des 4 4 6 et 4 6 kelly
3 b 6 donc on est dans une eau est
indienne qui ne dit pas son nom parce
que les les blancs n'ont pas joué qui a
laissé trois donc il ya eu foule b4 mais
c'est la même idée que dans lost année
on contrôle beaucoup ici fortement avec
les noirs la case e 4 avec le fou et
c'est pourquoi pour empêcher l'invasion
éventuelle des blancs sur le centre donc
j'ai 3 alors là on veut mettre vis-à-vis
face à face où vous faut être versée à
la fois ci ça aussi c'est la petite
pique quart proviennent au lieu de
mettre le fou en baisse est tout de
suite on génère on va le mettre mais pas
tout de suite
pouf on dit ok tu veux mettre ton poule
à mais alors qu'est ce que tu fais de
mon attaque sur le pion parce qu'en
général ce fou protège ses pions donc
évident ça force le coup suivant b3 mais
les noirs considère que ce coût a faibli
un tout petit peu les cases noires
puisque les pions sur blanc le nom est
donc bon mais ils estiment que ce qui ce
qu'ils ont fait l'arrêt est intéressant
pour cela les empêche pas après de jouer
sous 17
et puis il y aura moins de moines
défense sur le coup chou bekkat qui doit
intervenir dans cette reste indienne
voilà tient surtout b4 on peut pas nous
notamment on ne peut pas jouer
qu'avaient les citrons mais plus puis en
b2 ça oblige à la food & 2 alors voilà
la petite astuce si on joue fawcett
parce qu'en fait les noirs estime
qu'après fou mais qu'après le courroux
des deux et bien en fait se fout il mal
placé et à la limite ils moins bien
placés là que là donc on vous fawcett
pourquoi parce qu'évidemment là on
pouvait ici le fou était encore là on
pouvait choisir de le développer en b
ou en a trois et là c'est plus possible
bon donc les noirs estime que ce fou
devra bouger donc finalement les blancs
ça les gêne plus qu'autre chose a noté
kissy d'ailleurs la dame protège plus
non plus le pion des quatre voies la
foulée deux c6 évidemment il fallait
faire quelque chose contre l'attack
potentiel du fou sur la tour à 8
on aurait pu tenter aussi fou mais sais
tu pourquoi pas pour mettre en vis-à-vis
bon c'est 6 pourquoi parce que peut-être
que les noirs veulent jouer de toute
façon des 5 et ainsi sur consolide de la
casse des 5
c'était aussi une possibilité petit rock
des 5 voilà on est on est en plein dans
nos talents fous ces trois voilà donc on
a choisi de mettre le fond ces trois
voiliers s'il avait été là on aurait
joué 1 c2 en b2b en jouant c3 mais on
enlève quand même une case de
développement du cavalier donc il va
sans doute devoir se développer en d2 ce
qu'à manille
il ya une petite petite finesse quand
même oui ici c'est que a priori le pion
c4 peut être y briller par une loi c'est
vrai alors on pourrait envisager
maintenant pour les noirs de prendre
effectivement ses 4 il faut pas oublier
cette possibilité même si on est en
baisse c'est bien de l'expliquer mais il
ya quand même la réplique cavaliers cinq
ici alors peut être un peu gênante pour
les noirs exactement cavalier e 5 avec
une double attaque sur le pion c6
regarder le foot et d'eau qu'ils se
réveillent et évidemment avec la reprise
sur ces quatre là voilà la réponse qu'il
suffit à justifier le fait qu'on peut
laisser ce pion en prise parce qu'en
fait on finalement on laisse les noirs
abandonné le centre c'est une sorte
d'abandon du centre que de prendre comme
ça d'un pion soir au centre sur le côté
c'est pas neutre ici on doit bien ça
réveille le potentiel des pièces
blanches
donc après fou c3
les noirs ne prennent pas le pion c4
mais font le petit rock et maintenant
cavalier bd deux voies la maintenance en
plus ça protège ses 4es en plus alors en
d2 évidemment non mais le cavalier une
peu à peu près naturel à sa place
absolument nature laissé ses trois mais
en d2 et bien aussi puisqu'il peut
proposer plus tard d'aidé à la poussée
de 4 et un thème toujours méfiant pour
une évasion du centre qu'elle avait 17
pour in war on la développe en symétrie
de ce côté-là et voyages ou des tubes et
de n'envoyer que les noirs avaient
raison c'est à dire que ce coup fourré
l'un des deux a obligé fous ces trois
puits ou b2 qui n'a pas fait un bon coup
si on avait joué et fawcett bébé blanc
ont regagné en comptant de plus si on se
coule fois joué trois fois exact tours
s'est vite tour c'est un donc ça c'est
normal on va développer nos tours ici
sur la colombie où des échanges sont
possibles ici donc l'ouverture de la
colonne est probable ce sont des places
naturel pour les tours qui puisait la
tour noire l'a pas intérêt à rester en
huit puisque les vis-à-vis du fou j'ai
donc en plus la tour ici était en
vis-à-vis du fou effectivement donc on
aime bien la mettre ici elle est active
alors maintenant le coup c'est 5 qui
vient d'être jouée par les noirs toku
naturel aussi une fois qu'on considère
que finalement les noirs du côté noir
qu'on contrôle bien le centre et bien
c'est le c'est l'heure pour jouer le
coup libérateur classique dans ce type
d'ouverture du pion gamme c5 pour
attaquer le pion du centre blanc à noter
que le faut si c'est toujours bien ici
puisqu'il exerce une pression continue
sur ces quatre avec l'aide du pillon des
donc c'est pas un fou neutre à noter que
quand même derrière il ya un pion à eux
deux il ya aussi une tour on peut pas
faire n'importe quoi arrêter blanc il
faut tenir compte de ce petit fou qui
qui n'est pas un fou inactifs c'est un
fou qui fait pression et tournait donc
on enlève la tour soit même les noirs en
lui la tour du fise à vis du fou est ici
les blancs enlève la tour du fise à vis
du fou aussi
et en plus on prépare sa part toujours
la poussée de 4 voilà qu'un des
objectifs des blancs qui s'est
effectivement une plante fort donc c'est
prendrait quatre maintenant pour les
noirs qui élimine rupture centrale c'est
toujours bien si vous pouvez prendre un
point central fait le ca peut pas être
mal hein sauf combinaison particulière
on reprend les cavaliers ici donc alors
on n'a pas peur de pousser comme ça de
ce type là parce que ça affaiblir et les
pions on aurait par exemple cavaliers 5
en or et qui les tirait profit justement
de 7 pouces et un n'oubliez pas d'actes
chaque pion poussé laisse dans son
sillage des caisses faible exactement
donc il faut éviter avec les noirs ce
type de choses donc maintenant c'est
l'heure pour les noirs justement pour
fou bessette ils veulent consolider
leurs pions des 5 parce que la menace
des blancs pouvaient être de prendre des
5 et de créer ce qu'on appelle un pion
isolé après la prise du camion pourrait
peut-être même prendre du fou quoique ne
pas donner se fout les boules hier par
la présence des cinq y avait une entrée
possible du cavalier oui surtout voilà
en c6 ou de la tour on sait si ce même
éventuellement pour doubler ou f5 sert à
prévoir il pensait 5calais penser on
pouvait jouer surtout voilà c'est sabine
et surtout on ajouté en relief 5 puisque
on attaque g7 avec le fou et la prise
est pas possible puisque ya le fou qui
aurait pris deux cavaliers d'ailleurs ça
va être un des thèmes de la partie d'un
des thèmes donc à 3 donc ça alors
maintenant libre en vol on avait dit que
les caisses tout à l'heure que les
classements avait été affaibli parce que
le fait que les blancs étaient tous sur
noir un jour à troy on enlève cette
possibilité tout simplement ça c'est une
première chose et aussi pourquoi pas on
envisage de jouer surtout b4 qui va
enlever la casse c'est 5,5 à ses 5 et
quand une belle case parce que si on ne
joue qu'à nécessaire pour garder on
commence à avoir un beau contrôle de la
case 4 avec possibilité d'évasion
pourquoi pas x 8
or ces classiques aussi ça se joue un
petit recul
du fou pourquoi parce que ce fourbe et 7
est presque en l'air entre l'émissaire
qui n'est protégé par rien donc on peut
faire des combinaisons avec à la fin une
prise du fou pourquoi pas par le fou
j'ai deux et on craint des menaces au
centre voire probablement sait jamais en
bref en tout cas en ouvrant les lignes
alors quand je vois un à huit ce fou
sera toujours protégé parce qu'il ya un
deux trois pièces lourdes qui le protège
donc on enlève toute possibilité
c'est un coup prophylactique c'est bien
typique du style de karpov
ça permet au noir d'envisager la
possibilité de prendre le pion c4 ça
permet effectivement maintenant au noir
de menaces et pourquoi pas ou en tout
cas de proposer un échange en c4 puisque
le fou et protégé alors que si on avait
pris le pouls précédent et bien phu
prendre mais c'est ton père une pièce
donc c'est prendre des 5 pour les blancs
calais prenait 5 et la larsen joue son
fameux coup qui l'a préparé donc il est
conséquent larsen puisqu'ils jouent eux
quatre jolis seins enfin on avance
qu'entre clients du pion roi on a une
belle pièce au centre on a une
magnifique diagonale qui pointe vers le
roi en juin 4 on a chassé on va chasser
ce cube ce qu'harry centrale qui est
toujours bien donc on a une
prépondérance centrale à une quête
avantage blanc des espaces bon il n'est
pas forcément significatif au point de
gagner mais il est quand même là et
quand même une pression blanche avec
deux beaux fous d'un petit ap
ici une autre qui contrôle les cases
blanches donc on a une belle un beau
contrôle qu'elle 5 et 6 et là à regarder
qu'à laisser 4 joli coup c'est agréable
ouais c'est une belle entrée du cavalier
là on a deux cavaliers au centre ases-cc
hâter les cats et agréable pour les
blancs alors laissez de calais sont
magnifiques
celui-là il contrôle les cases des six
n'est qu'à 1,5
celui-là l'autre ils contrôlent les cas
ces six ans mais ça fait des belles
cases regardez moi tout ça c'est beau
c'est un beau réseau de case centrale
qui appuie sur les petites faiblesses du
camp noir c'est quand même c'est beau à
l'oeil quand même ça se voit tout de
suite que c'est bien à 6 alors assise
l'idée des noirs est simple je joue à 6
ici pour simplement jouer b5 et chasser
ce cavalli qui pousse un pas de case et
pour priver et pour priver les blancs de
la possibilité de jouer cavalier des
cintres et ensuite cavalier des si ce
n'est sur une autre menace et aurait pu
être de jouer effectivement cavaliers
vaisselle etc deux cavaliers contrôler
la case des six avec le soutien de la
dame blanche et situe comme une caste
pénible parce que ça t'a créé la tour où
va la tour si la torah n'arrive pas à
tenir en huitièmes et bien la colonne
c'est va être aux mains des blancs et ça
c'est pas agréable
donc il faut réagir quand même et larsen
en profitent maintenant pour combiner
alors ça c'est important ce coup c'est
déjà une combine parce que c'est chaud
il ya quand même des prises partout
à noter que le coût faux projet de
serait une faute puisque on prendrait
d'abord le clavier six attaquants le fou
aux 7es en cas de prise maintenant on
reprend on a gagné une pièce
donc attention aujourd'hui ces
manoeuvres quand il ya une contiennent
histoire de prise par le pion de prise
par la pièce c'est souvent la prise par
le pion qui al'avantage ici puisque le
pion peu peut aller prendre leur menacés
ils peuvent menacer il attaquerait en
plus les blancs n'ont pas peur de perdre
deux pions il peut rester en prise
tandis que le fou qui a pris angers de
lui on n'avait pas envie de le perdre
mais non ça fait quand même une grosse
pièce donc câbles et des 5
donc ça oblige ça ce pion efforts alors
ce pion efforts pourquoi parce qu'il est
soutenu par la tour et puis ils
contrôlent la casse faible maintenant
des six qui est contrôlé aussi par le
câble et c4
donc on voit que le conte le camp nou en
maintenant non seulement il est sous
pression de la domination blanche sur le
centre mais ils commencent à être sous
pression dans son propre camp et s'il ya
plus de cases pour bouger
c'est pas bon alors les gens aimeraient
sûrement ajouter de la pression sur des
six par leurs cavaliers mais ils peuvent
plus aller en bessin qu'on a dit on peut
pas venir effectivement des cinq mètres
haies et larsen a une autre idée est il
arrivé en d6 ou en tout cas menacé d'y
arriver
voilà et c'est un peu l'idée qu'on avait
déjà cité un peu tout à l'heure vous
regardez c'est très jolie cavalière cinq
magnifiques lecavalier vian f5 emilien
ou alors on peut se dire au premier coup
d'oeil mais les emprises oui mais les
noirs peuvent pas le prendre puisque en
font peu mais si on prend et bien c'est
le cadet des scènes qui saute on échange
des fous et en échange de quoi on a
gardé un pion central et les noirs eux
ont un pion qui est parti du centre donc
on a une prépondérance centrale avec une
puissance des pièces lourdes derrière
extrêmement forte
est ce bien aussi ce peu après joué en
no 6 pour ce pur le 5 peut pousser ans
le 6 pourquoi pas pour affaiblir le
heureux que noir il faudra faire sauter
le pion aux 7 et il peut même y avoir
des attaques de maths donc qu' on prend
un f5 de la part de karpov parce que
attention ce cavalier est quand même
extrêmement dangereux pour deux raisons
1 il peut s'échanger contre le le fort
flo7 qui est important parce que c'est
lui qui tient des cases noires puis
défendre et aussi peut faire les gens de
l'es6 et il peut venir en d6 alaric le
problème qu'on avait dit tout à l'heure
que fait la tour maintenant attention on
a un cavalier qui rentrait dans le camp
ennemi donc deux possibilités on peut
aussi même prendre le fouet venir en d6
avec l'invasion et il ya un éventuel des
menus comme g4 ou d'abord cavaliers
pranger 7
il ya aussi la possibilité de jouer dame
g4 menace maths c'est trop c'est trop
facile ça vaut largement un pion donc il
faut faire attention à ça donc pu rompre
avec 5 fu prend des cinq fonds prend
d'en prendre
après ces échanges qui était forcée et
bien larsen est en position de force ils
tiennent tout le centre en fait c'est là
qu'on voit l'importance du centre tout
le centre est pris la casse des six est
faible protégé par le pion on va voir
que larsen va profiter de tout ça avec
maestria puisqu'il tient toutes les
possibilités d'invasion du camp adverse
alors qu'avaient laissé cinq de karpov
attaque le pion b 3 mai alors évidemment
larsen et change pas sa dame qui est
dominante au centre
à noter que les showcases blanche n'est
pas attaquable ni par le fou n'est même
pas le cavalier qui est quand même très
loin de pouvoir menacer cette dame
donc elle est puissante à l'accueil sur
le roi elle a un oeil
de l'autre côté on va pas l'échanger
contre une dame qui est les connaissez
dans son camp puis elle a un oeil sur b3
en transparence on est en va exactement
après karel et des six non seulement en
attaque la tour mais on a protégé cette
pseudo attaque du cavalier alors à noter
attention maintenant que ce fou aussi
devient extrêmement fort puisque sur des
coupes ultérieure comme si il peut y
avoir attaques de g7 avec possibilité de
maths il faut être extrêmement prudent
bon c'est karpov même attention c'est un
défenseur hors pair dame 17 alors il n'a
pas protégé la tour ça peut nous sembler
et will étrange alors il protège pas la
tour karpov à ce moment là qu'est ce qui
se dit que la dame blanche est dans
l'air puisque la dame blanche est un
leurre et larsen mais il dit mais oui
mais quand même
cavaliers feront tour même pas peur
alors c'est peut-être karpov n'a pas vu
ce coup puisque d'un 17 effectivement
est très certainement une faute alors
est-ce qu'il ya autre chose de possible
que dans 17 oui on aurait pu jouer un
coup comme tour ses sept tours c'est 7
avec à l'idée de venir peut-être en 17
on n'a qu'à laisser 5 qui peut peut-être
devenir revenir en 6 pour bloquer et
peut-être qu'on peut tenir en étant
extrêmement précis dans une position on
est quand même très très resserré ça
c'est possible mais karpov n'a sans
doute pas vu cette possibilité ou là
oublié on est en glisse quand même donc
ça peut l'expliquer il vous donne 17 mai
larsen quand même pourquoi parce que on
a pris une tour contre cavaliers donc si
on reprend moi c'est possible on aura
perdu la qualité plus que ça d'ailleurs
parce que si tout reprend alors si tu
auras oui ces trois ans c'est la
catastrophe on adam prend six tours
prend à simplement bien sûr d'un
programme d'un pc nas est sûr qu à l epr
en regarder on a encore la tour qui
saute donc ça va pas donc sûr que là il
prend ses 8
une autre possibilité c'est de dire mais
non mais la dame sait ce que c'est ce
que de se dire car pauvre tu peux pas
prendre la tour mais regardez up
clac échec donc on est obligé de jouer
pour la suite et on récupère la dame est
vrai bilan des courses il manque une
tour et un flux net au noir c'est à dire
que la partie est finie alors cavaliers
prendre ces 8
eh bien il faut reprendre de la nomme
alors l'avantagé est énorme puisque non
seulement davantage centrale de larsen
est toujours là mais l'avantagé matériel
est manifeste et la qualité plus plus
plus un clouage du cavalier si on est là
c'est l'horreur parce que lecavalier ne
peut pas bouger sous peine alors
heureusement heureusement il faut pas
toujours paniquer sur les cloches comme
ça gagnent possibilité de défense voilà
qui est tout simple on peut sauver ta me
6 voilà on peut jouer dame assise
puisque sur dame prend dames on a on a
cavaliers prend et si les blancs
prennent aux curieux on peut prendre
tout simplement donc les prévisions
annoncent ils blanc prennent aux
cavaliers c'est la dame qui perdu par le
voilà donc la dame est attaqué et si la
dame
prend on peut sortir du cavalier mais
c'est quand même ce qui se passe puisque
après cette prise bien les noirs n'ont
pas récupéré leur structure de pions on
aurait aimé reprendre du pied on ne peut
pas la kabylité emprise et les blancs
vont pénétrer dans le camp ennemi par le
simple tour c6 et ramassage scolaire
comme le dit le grand maître on ramasse
les petits élèves qui traînent sur le
bord de la route alors fou d'éviter
forcé pour protéger mais s'efface et
passifs bien sûr et maintenant on active
l'autre tour d'où la force des tours on
va pénétrer peut-être en d6 on décède
pourquoi pas un petit tri sur le fond on
active nos pièces au maximum f4 alors
pourquoi être 4/4 peuvent se débarrasser
d'un pion qui est doublé essayé
d'échanger ici c'est l'idée est là
simplement les blancs continuent de
l'autre côté alors à 4 alors l'idée d' à
quatre ça peut être de jouer par exemple
on pourrait jouer fous ces trois puis à
que fait alors là on attaque le plan b
si c'était un cas de prises prise mais
le foot pro tech à 5
et c'est le pion à 6 ce qui est perdu
est en un pion passer pour aller finir
la partie
donc là maintenant hashtag le karpov qui
lance son bateau alors il évite un petit
mec du couloir
et puis il va essayer d'affaiblir en
solo drap blanc et pourquoi pas trouver
son salut dans quelques combinaisons
oui avec un pion par exemple l'orage 3
ou en f3 il y aurait des menaces de
maths du couloir qui qui se feraient
jour éventuellement puisque le roi
serait oui on pourrait jouer de la casse
j'ai dû à chaque instant je crois et
puis on a un problème avec moi c'est ça
bon ceci la tour on voit pas comment la
tient pour l'instant non
alors ton 17
oui on met une tour sur un septième jeu
toujours bien quand il voit son côté a
toujours bien oui et puis il ya bien sûr
des menaces de type maintenant tombée
c'est tout surtout torah c'est celle que
fait le pinot noir sur le bouche on
affaiblit encore sa position
on peut envisager de prendre pourquoi
pas pu pousser trois essais perdu c'est
une autre façon de gagner le pion tours
pourquoi pas on croit g2 voilà ça y est
alors la scène évite de se faire coincer
le roi g5
il me semble à tous ici car pendant
cette position et à ça ça fait mal ça
pour ces huit bien sûr un rôle à oncle
où il ya du ramassage aussi dans l'air
ici on cloue le fou des huit sur la tour
donc protection et la part de karpov
protège son matériel et b5 voilà c'est
l'heure alors ça le coude b5 fixe le
plan b si sur noir et or en plus à noter
que l'objectif des chèques
il y aura une petite échec ici donc
après un bep à prendre mais j'ai quatre
alors là la menace attention des noirs
c'est de faire menaçant entre guillemets
ça peut jouer 3 pour isoler ce roi et
l'enfermé joue h théâtre un tout
simplement larsen en cas de 1 peut-être
de f3 il peut jouer un coup comme le
voyage de peut-être il peut aussi sortir
le mans par là attention là et ça c'est
faible émission si ça saute le reste a
sauté bon notation séoul à take up
voilà je vais prendre trois échecs
apprend f3 alors là il veut se trouver
son salut ici en disant je vais essayer
de prendre plus tard ce pion et avoir un
petit pion pas sinon c'est foutu
à ce qu'on dit c'est fou des quatre donc
là c'est simple si cavaliers prend le
fou alors on peut essayer maintenant de
prendre mais sur ce four mais sûrement
mais là c'est pas de problème
ça marche pas très bien parce qu'il ya
toujours des huit attaques la tour est
en cas de prise échec et le cavalier
ramasser donc food et 4 et la cave léger
cinq échecs de karpov encore voyez ça
gesticule encore on est en glisse donc
c'est normal il revient fou e3 tous à
présent un coût serait forte à sanaa il
prend même pas le pion regarder il joue
là parce que le quart ya plus de quinze
cavaliers n'a plus de quasi complètement
dominés et en fait si on regarde bien
c'est un zoom grand angle et noir quoi
qu'il joue vont affaiblir leur position
voilà si on joue le fou ou bargou
d'abord si on bouge bien on va perdre le
pion b6 il rend d'abord un échange et
puis le plan réussisse et perdu en fait
pas je vous la tour non plus causé à
perdre la perte d'une pièce on peut pas
il ya que le roi qu'on peut jouer pour
en fait plus que le roi mais simplement
pas dire qu'on ne décolle de la défense
de la tour 8
et oui donc faux b6 il faut prendre v6
puisque sur faut prendre ou à tourcoing
tours donc il le fait quand même y'a
plus de coûts pour karpov 2.8 et après
encore quelques coups qu'avait léger 5 e
6 clouage ça fait que ça fait mal ici
bras et après la prise amendement de
karpov évidemment puisque la menace et
de ses deux fers dame
donc faudrait jouer ou si c'est pour
perdre le fou ou alors si on prend avec
lecavalier est simplement un clouage et
la tour prendra le cavalier beaucoup
suivant voilà une magnifique partie un
blitz mais très beau avec domination
centrale le rapide exploitation et puis
finalement de karpov qui fait une gaffe
qui perd une qualité sur une sur une
gaffe métiers du ou à la pression des
blancs alors qu'il y avait déjà plus
beaucoup de coups faciles à jouer et
finalement larsen démontre en 87 qu'il
est encore capable de battre un champion
du monde même si c'est en blitz
ça reste un bon résultat mais parce que
il fait preuve d'une grande précision
et puis effectivement il ya une gaffe et
ça se joue sur quelque chose d'assez
tactique mais c'est le résultat aussi
d'une domination stratégique
ces nominations stratégiques au design
un hasard de toute façon même sans la
gaffe je pense que l'art scène aurait
fini par l'emporter puisqu'ils avaient
vraiment l'avantagent au centre
ces contrats visent la greffe est
provoqué par l'impression de tout
voilà donc un grand joueur que ce larsen
qui a fait l'histoire à la fois mais par
ces grands résultats par le fait qu'il
faisait partie des meilleurs joueurs qui
dans taux est aussi aussi parce que bon
mais il fait quand même partie de ces
joueurs qui ont mis en valeur ou bobby
fischer même ça compte aussi
son nom reste à coller à cette lourde
défaite à denver il n'y a pas de non
plus de grande carrière sans avoir des
opposants de qualité alors ça nous
faisait partie et sa perte aussi face à
s'afficher en 6 0 ça reste un match
historique et c'est justement rester un
match mémorable parce que c'était larsen
c'était mes bras non plus n'importe quel
joueur et ce résultat là et ils seront
autant this man 2 parce qu'on pensait
pas du tout qu'il était possible de
battre leur scène avec un tel écart
parce que larsen faisait partie des
prétendants à la couronne mondiale et il
est il était pas très loin de jouer une
finale de championnat du monde il a raté
de peu sans doute des 69 1 où il était
sans doute proches de ceux de cette
potentialité il n'aurait pas dû naître à
la même époque que fichiers en voilà
marcel saule voilà merci jérôme pour ce
cette émission importante sur un joueur
qui a marqué l'époque richard yens bent
larsen au revoir et à bientôt sur une
diagonale tv pour d'autres grands
champions